it's time for another challenge charlie
Christmas edition ah so it's Christmas
today ah like you needed need to tell
you that by the way happy birthday baby
Jesus hope you got everything you wanted
because it's Christmas I asked my
followers on Twitter to suggest
Christmassy related challenges which you
did in your masses get it
masses mass like midnight mass Christmas
and my favorite by far was to get
wrapped up like a Christmas present so
that's what I'm doing today my siblings
Bridey and will are going to help me do
this so without further ado let's get on
with it
oh wow I'm Weiss gobble why are you
scrubbing I'm not Freddie I'm Liliana hi
to the ugly excuse me oh oh
when you do my heads can you make sure I
have I holes in my head long so you grab
the other side
[Music]
you're doing slightly don't see anything
I am a Christmas present I'm gonna try
and break free
Charlie's completed well wasn't that fun
for everyone involved now before I go I
have another Christmassy thing to tell
you about I recently made four videos
for the BBC hanging out behind the
scenes of Doctor Who which was a lot of
fun for me because I am a massive fan of
the show if you're interested in seeing
those just click on the picture of me
Matt Smith and a badger puppet that'll
take you to little playlists of the four
videos so enjoy
I will see in the new year and stuff bye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool why are you
still here click on the picture you're
not interested okay Merry Christmas